[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
yours I prefer to think that Dear John
Hank it's a podcast where two brothers
will answer your questions give you to
be subversive and bring you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon how you do it John I'm alright
Hank you know that line from Rushmore I
ain't even here sergeant I'm a Cheyenne
Wyoming
you don't write and they get you to get
the reference because I previously
referred to it on the podcast the point
is this how we're gonna exist if this is
now a continuation of the intro where I
just say how you doin Jonathan you quote
Rushmore like if that are new I've got a
new bit point I've been in Cheyenne
Wyoming for far too long and I've kind
of lost my sense of self but I can't
leave Cheyenne Wyoming right now and
yeah how are you I'm good I want to tell
you a little story about how I was
eating a Clif Bar 1-1 ray by which I
mean yesterday and walking down the
stairs onto my in my back yard so I
could go out of my office so walking
down these stairs is like four or five
stairs I couldn't tell you how many
stairs there are exactly and I'm eating
a Clif Bar and and because I was
preoccupied thinking about all of the
interesting things in my life and also
how great this Clif Bar was I I didn't
know how many steps there were and I
thought I was done with the steps but it
wasn't right and so I you know about but
let's say a second and a half later was
on my but having not entirely sure about
the situations regarding my ankles and
hands but feeling okay and then I looked
down in my hands and I'm like where's my
Clif Bar so I fell down this these
stairs and like I think I'm okay I got a
little bit of pain in my leg and wrist
from catching myself but my Clif Bar
what where did it go do you know where I
went John I don't and it better be good
because the rest of this story has not
been great so far it was in my mouth oh
the whole thing just shot right into the
mouth but I just I liked quick put it in
my mouth while I was falling bit down on
it hold it real hard and then I was like
where did it
oh I can't find my glyph bar and essence
to me with my glasses all the time very
similar problem with my glasses I'm sure
at some point during this podcast I'll
be like where's my phone and it'll be
like oh right I'm on I'm on the phone
with my brother Jon podcasting yeah I've
been SIA when I'm under a lot of stress
I do that more often like weirdly when
I'm stressed out I've become more
obsessive about checking things but I
also become far more likely to lose them
so I'll become very obsessive about
checking that I have my wallet for
instance but I become infinitely more
likely to lose my wallet
I find that there are very few upsides
you know how like people often think
that like portray mental illness as
having secret advantages you know like
you can oh yeah that's what we want we
want that to be a thing where it's like
us but but we get something out of at
least right like the genius is close to
madness and whatever I thought has just
not been my experience my experience has
been that it's just it's just an
unfortunate thing mm-hmm I don't have
let's move on to questions for our
listeners this question comes wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait you didn't
bring us a poem I didn't bring you out
of a poem for today Hank I to be a
totally honest with you I have been in
Cheyenne Wyoming for so long that I had
do not I I did I am not prepared for
this podcast I'm just gonna level with
you Hank like I this is not going I'm
not about to express my best work and my
best work as podcasting isn't even very
good I've got a short poem for you here
opaque metallic permanent ink no shaking
required to start quick drying fade and
water-resistant ink is that from the
side of a sharpie it's from the back of
a package of metallic sharpies yes John
I spent a lot of time thinking about
sharpies these days this question comes
from Meredith who writes Dear John and
Hank I've recently begun the process of
digitizing my wardrobe meaning that I've
been taking pictures of every item of
clothing I own editing it then uploading
it to a special digital closet app the
only reason I'm doing this is because it
is my ultimate dream to not have to get
out of bed in the morning in order to
pick out an outfit
however the whole process is proving to
be incredibly time-consuming the irony
of the situation has dawned on me I'm
putting in a bunch of work just so I can
be lazy my question is is it really
laziness if you have to put in work to
be lazy laziness has always been a part
of my identity and I feel as though I'm
starting to lose my edge or maybe I'm
moving a level up on the laziness matter
I can't decide what are your thoughts
yours in questionable ironic laziness
Meredith yeah I think you're becoming
next-level lazy which is fantastic I
think I think you know really good
laziness
it could be gonna be the good kind of
lazy you should invest in a future
laziness knowing that you will want to
stay in bed is a grit as in like
investing in that well I'm particularly
that staying in bed thing which is so
lovely to be able to do that until like
shave a little bit of time off of this
like transition into into being upright
and cold which is too unpleasant things
to to give yourself those five extra
minutes and also like I think there's a
little bit of like you like spending
time with your closet and doing this and
being a little bit like you're in the
movie clueless and what a yeah like
you're you're spending time doing a
thing that you enjoy doing and also
you're allowing yourself to relax a
little bit more that's great
yeah I have an analogous experience with
cataloging my home library Henkes you
know I've been cataloging my home
library since 2007 I've never finished
but every time I have a spare couple of
hours I get on my library app and I
catalog a few more books and I'm
ostensibly doing this so that I stopped
losing books I find that I consistently
lose the books that I most need at any
given moment I can find every book
except for the one I need and so the
idea is that I'm doing this so that like
future me will never lose a book but the
reality is that I'm doing it because I
like cataloging my home library there's
like working so that you can live your
best life rather than working so that
you can work so that you can work so
that you can work and I understand like
I definitely have a thing in me where
like I want to I'd like Drive myself to
work hard because I feel like I have an
obligation to do
like to do the things that I have the
ability to do to you know employ people
and to create things that people are
gonna enjoy and and you know project for
awesome like make the world a better
place but like there's there there's
also like I also have to counter that
with some amount of like I am working so
that I can like do the things that I
want to do in that and that I'd like to
do like spending time with my family and
traveling and eating delicious pizza and
laying in bed for five minutes longer
than I otherwise good I don't know why
I'm working I mean you are about three
years ahead of me in your like midlife
crisis and I am already pretty deep in
it so I can't imagine where you're at I
have no idea
ah that's honestly hey like I have no
idea why I work especially why the last
few months I have been working so hard
I'm sorry yeah I want to underscore the
fact that I'm not really here hey I am
definit I definitely have those moments
when Catherine will ask me a question
and then it'll be like a solid 30
seconds before I'm able to answer
because I'm like yeah I've been like
that with my family for like two and a
half months oh man pretty consecutively
I know it's been very bad it's been very
bad I but I think on the other hand like
this has been a very creatively
productive time for me and in a way like
that's the only way I can do it's the
only way I can do it like it's not I
find that like I can't really work part
time on most things like when I'm
working on something I tend to be pretty
deeply involved in it and it's really
hard for me to be able to like put stuff
down but then you know hopefully that
also applies to when I'm not working
like I'm you know present instead of
being like half there or whatever I feel
like we're in fertile ground so what
that is maybe some pretty deeply
unrelated to Meredith's question but I
do want to continue and say that I have
bit like the there is this thing about
like about writing a book in particular
and and like that says that I'm writing
a book well other this is what I'm
saying about me no I'm about yoga that I
like I you like I have to have my head
live in the world yeah a lot or else I
don't get good stuff out of it and I've
started out just in the last couple of
weeks started to like really apply
myself to the sequel to the book that I
haven't finished because the book itself
is sort of in it like in-between II
space where I can't I shouldn't be
working on it because it's people are
looking at it who aren't me
and so like I would I want to work a
little bit on the sequel before I
finished the book so that I can set up
the sequel well and and I will just be
sitting there at dinner and like living
in the world of the book and having no
idea that my mind is in a space that
inside of a physical reality and I like
and I don't feel like I can get good
creativity from this other world without
having my eat like without having my
mind all the way inside of it
right that's I call that space Cheyenne
Wyoming yeah I I agree I mean I think
it's really difficult to to get yourself
out of that when you're in it and also
you kind of don't want to because it's
productive it's a productive space and
for me like it's a really like exciting
space in some ways because it's a you
know it's a way out of out of oneself
it's a moment where you don't feel like
you're kind of like stuck inside of this
self shaped prison and that's very
appealing but on the other hand like it
does after a while I mean this has been
this has been a while for me you start
to want to be able to like engage with
the world and I I guess for me like it's
like if I'm there I'm never really all
the way like in this world like I
and I know I know we all have that
experience if like you're in a
conversation and you one of the things
you start to notice is like it's totally
possible to trick people like it's
totally possible to make people believe
that that that you're really there and
you're like oh my god like 99% of my
social interactions are so incredibly
superficial that that people don't know
that I'm not here and I and I would have
no way of knowing if they weren't here
or if they're not here but yeah I think
so for several of the last months or
much of the last few months might that
has been the case for me and and it's
nice in some ways and in other ways I'm
looking forward to it ending which
hopefully it will soon I mean the other
thing is that I never quite know when
it's over right like I whenever you're
working on something you you never know
when you're able to let it go like I'm
always fascinated by people like visual
artists who make lots of artwork and you
know they make more than like one
painting every three or four years which
is my rate of production like how on
earth do they know that they're finished
you know I mean how on earth when you're
making an abstract painting do you look
at it and you're like done I just don't
like I admire the I admire that ability
to to talk about the moment you're
finished are we still talking about
digitizing your wardrobe I don't think
so but I think that we I think that we
got to the root of Meredith's question
and and I want to ask a question that's
gonna bring you all the way into this
world with something that you were very
passionate about so you're gonna you're
gonna be here for this one it's from
Sarah who asks dear Hank and John I live
in Germany but I will be traveling to
the US in a few weeks is there anything
that I have to eat or drink while I am
there I've already put diet dr. pepper
on my list since that's something I have
never seen in a German store any other
suggestions vivere disk' said quad to
tomorry Sarah I looked that one up it
says remember to live or learn to live
but remember death hmm thanks Sarah
I needed that first off I've just found
out Hank said I can't move to Germany I
wanted to
because it seems like a great country
Hank and I are fascinated by the German
way of doing business what's it called
Hank the middle Scot the middle shot or
made inspectors I want to do when we
grow up is run a middle shot but I can't
move there because there's no there's no
regular access to diet dr. pepper it
might as well be the frickin moon I
don't know what do you eat in America
that you can't eat elsewhere I feel like
we've done a really good job of
exporting our terrible diets yeah well I
mean so first of all America has like
every flavor of chip we don't we there's
definitely flavors of chip that you can
you can't get in America there's not
doesn't doesn't tend to be ketchup chips
here which are in other places paprika
Pringles are my very favorite kind of
Pringle and you can't get them in
America but we have so many flavors of
chips we are really into chips guys like
we have they're like that the weird like
like indie brands like Tim's with like
that and you've got like the sweet Maui
onion from the Hawaiian chip people and
you got the got like weird they also
make like a spicy barbecue one and
you've got to eat barbecue chips so
basically you got to go to a grocery
store and just buy the chip flavors you
don't recognize also you're gonna want
to have a corn dog also you're gonna
want to have biscuits and gravy also
you're gonna want to have corn fried
steak corn fried steak that's weird
Corrigan fried steak chicken fried steak
with gravy fried steak is also a weird
idea if you're not American yeah but in
I don't know do they have sausage gravy
in other countries because I don't think
I've ever seen it and I've just the one
thing that they definitely don't do as
well in other countries as they do in
the United States is barbecue ah you're
gonna want to have if you eat meat I
think you're gonna want to have some
nice pulled pork barbecue and then the
other thing so I actually have spent a
fair amount of time in Berlin and I
don't know if Sarah's from Berlin but I
thought they had all of the major foods
except apparently diet dr. pepper and
barbecue
so that's all so I wanted to say that
when Hank says chips he is referring to
the item that in the rest of the world I
believe is called crisp yes that is
correct I'm talking about American chips
the way chips should have always been
because they're shaped lipton it's not
just of course if you're visiting the
United States you're not just there to
to eat and drink you're also there to
have experiences and I guess the main
experience that I would recommend Sarah
is if you can get an injury or an
illness nothing serious nothing
life-threatening because what if when
you come to America what you really want
to experience is our healthcare system
and I think it would be very interesting
for you to just maybe like sprained
ankle something like that and just get
get a feel for it get a feel for the
expense get a feel for the efficiency
with which everything is done and then
go back to Germany just crazy jealous of
how well we do health care just be
deeply amay don't hurt yourself
I disagree with John I've just looked up
the etymology of the word chip John
because I feel very defensive of I'm
actually yeah Sarah do whatever you can
not to have not go to the doctor they're
just the act of going to the doctor's
like a hundred and twenty bucks so chip
comes of course from chipping something
off of something else like I like
chipping too young like stone off of a
stone a chip off the old block is this I
feel like if you're gonna take a potato
and you're gonna chip something off of
it it's gonna be more like a potato chip
in America than it's gonna be like a
chip in the UK where it's this like like
clearly a sliced diced thing where it's
like the long square rectangle thing I
think yeah I mean I like I'm not gonna
want to fight and die on this particular
Hill well I will so anybody just come I
want a year I want it yes and you but I
literally can't figure out how to yes
okay well and also when I look I got a
computer
chip I gotta say that looks more like a
potato chip in America than a chip in in
Europe how'd all this talk about a
delicious American food is making me
hungry do we have any like fruits and
vegetables we can recommend I feel like
we must have some are there like special
American vegetables do make are there
mangoes in Germany it's been a while
since I've been there if you don't have
fresh fruit in Germany Sarah and again I
am not totally sure about this but if
you don't have fresh fruit we do have
fresh fruit in America we have a bunch
of different kinds we have blueberries
raspberries mangoes sometimes we get
papayas not that often in Indiana but
sometimes so try out some fresh fruit
maybe it's only freeze dried also you
can have some green asparagus cuz I hear
in other countries asparagus is white
and that's weird
so have it our way and be like oh that
has different flavor no we're growing
purple asparagus in our in our home
garden well why didn't you start to
start out telling me that story instead
of being like I'm in Cheyenne Wyoming
Rushmore is great and you're terrible I
didn't say you were terrible it's I do
you think it's weird that you haven't
rewatched brush more when it's clearly
one of the best movies ever made let's
move on to this question from Natalie
who writes is it toothbrush water and
then toothpaste or is it toothbrush
toothpaste and then water I've been
having this debate actually with my
seven-year-old child tooth toothbrush
water toothpaste - I do toothbrush
toothpaste water
unfortunately that's incorrect but then
then the toothpaste doesn't get any
water on it oh no no no no no yeah that
that would also be an issue because the
correct order is toothbrush water
toothpaste water and you have to
remember to turn off the water between
each of those things which is the debate
that I'm currently having with Henry
Andrews a big believer that you turn the
water on and then you leave it on until
the end of time yeah well we could we
could we could it is uncle Hank need to
give a lesson in environmental
sustainability well I mean well I was
kind of having this debate with Henry
about you know like what amounts to a
couple of cups of
and then he reminded me that I recently
taught him that the water that comes out
of our sprinklers is the same as the
water heard that he drinks and he just
thought that was ludicrous he was like
but why would you pour that water on
grass and I was like yeah no you're not
wrong but he still did I don't know
waste is waste I I don't know I'm a
Henry is getting to that age now Hank
where he can kind of successfully debate
me you know like where occasionally he
wins you're like you know you're right
we're just dumping that onto the literal
ground so maybe maybe you can just leave
the water running fine child oh yeah
that's something right now my son can
debate me in exclusively one way by
punching me in the face and ripping my
glasses off which he does I regularly
feel like I feel like he doesn't punch
you in the face when he's angry like he
doesn't know about punching to be angry
he thinks it's cute or something I don't
know what do what do seven months olds
actually think about it definitely is
thinking about something like if we take
him to a new place you can't get him to
interact with any person because he's
like what is all of this what is this
room
what are these shapes what are what is
this what is this movement what is that
color and it which is great to just like
watch is like little brow furrow up and
be like mmm this is all very new I'm not
so sure about it this is a this is a
room I haven't been in before as that's
is that a good baby voice yeah that was
a good baby voice that sounded just like
the Alec Baldwin in boss baby both baby
a movie you didn't see the movie boss
baby
Oh turns out no is it as good as
Rushmore no it is not it is not as good
as Rushmore
however I am friends with the author of
the book boss baby and the book is
amazing have you read the book at least
no no John all right so the book well I
mean you would read it with your with
your tiny little baby yet but I'll send
you the boys version it is thinking of
like a like a like a 600 word novel boss
baby
it's a lovely picture book and it is
hilarious it's like it basically
imagines that you know like a baby in
their role as like the boss of the of
the family it's very very freaking cute
yeah
so anyway I we still read boss baby in
our family sometimes it's uh it's one of
the very few books that you will find on
Amazon that is an average rating of five
full stars mmm wow that is not easy to
accomplish yeah so um the author's name
is Mario Frazee and she is also really
really just a great great person and a
great author of children's book she
wrote another one of my favorite picture
books about James and Eamon what is that
book called - a couple of boys have the
best week ever or something like that
I'm gonna look it up at what point do I
remind John that he's literally been
talking about boss baby for like two
minutes sorry because I made a voice
that sounded like a voice to him it is
called a couple of boys have the best
week ever we move on what was the
question sorry I suddenly got engaged
with the world I was very excited I
don't even remember who I listen to
toothbrush toothpaste water or our
toothbrush water than toothpaste yeah we
don't know I think that I think that
you're gonna be okay either way
sometimes you know John honestly I'll do
tooth tooth tooth toothbrush no wait
toothbrush toothpaste and then mouth
yeah and that's not that's not that bad
of an outcome actually there's like that
first like first like four seconds where
it's like there's not enough water in my
mouth but then your mouth has a magical
ability to produce water and then you
have it in your mouth this question
comes from Rachel who asks dear Hank and
John do you think lin-manuel Miranda
ever listens to Hamilton just for
funsies does Michael Jordan watch Space
Jam every now and again Hank do you ever
listen to your own music John do you
ever reread your own books just because
you like them I must know your obedient
servant Rachel I like this question
mostly because it imagines that just as
Hamilton is the most important work
lin-manuel Miranda has ever done Space
Jam is the most important work Michael
Jordan has ever done like Oh Michael
Jordan what do you when you're looking
at back at your career what do you look
at well mostly Space Jam I'm not so much
being arguably the best NBA player of
all time I never watched that game where
with a hundred and four degree fever
I scored like sixty points in the NBA
playoff finals that's mostly I just
remarked Space Jam no I do not reread my
own books that I mean III read and
reread them plenty before they come out
III don't need to reread them after they
come out especially because I think I'll
just see things that I want to change
right now that makes a lot of sense I
sing my own songs all the time I sing
your songs all the time too actually but
that was not the question it's do I
listen to my own music and yes I also do
that there's this great thing about
listening to your own music which is
that like when I'm listening to like a
Billy Joel song I try to sound like
Billy Joel and when I'm listening to
like a queen song I try to sound like
Freddie Mercury but when I'm listening
to a hank green song I sound exactly
like that guy I don't even have to try I
[Laughter]
yeah I I have to say I sing your songs
more than I like listen to them on
Spotify because they're all inside of my
head from all those times touring
together what what tends to happen to me
is it like like my phone will
automatically connect to the Bluetooth
in my car and for whatever reason it's
like you know instead of playing for you
the audiobook you're listening to five
minutes ago here's a random selection
from the things on your phone and it'll
be like Bop by Hansen or like
demolition-derby one of the songs that
I'd never think about that I wrote and
I'll be like oh I would have done this a
little bit different but it's pretty
good
and then I'll sing along left uneven me
that's a different guy sick in that part
I don't know I poked I picked that do
you do you ever rewatch old vlogbrothers
videos okay god I used to be great at
this
yes yes yes yes
and like like and I'm sure that I will
do that two years from now i watch stuff
that i made this year and be like wow i
really i was really like like above and
beyond back then
yeah sometimes when i meet people at
like a grocery store or whatever and
they're like I used to watch your
YouTube videos I think to myself like
and I can't really blame them my YouTube
videos used to be great
I definitely like I will I I'm really
proud of some of the stuff we've done in
the last 12 months but like going back
and seeing something I did six years ago
that I worked really hard on there's
something very different about that
because I like forget I forget about how
hard I work on videos and then I'll
watch this thing gonna be like wow that
was like a significant amount of like
thought and time that went into that I
mean something like occasionally I like
I'll watch a video and be like I did
visual effects for that like like
there's like three videos that I've ever
done that I've had some component of
like superimposing something onto a
screen or you know like doing kinetic
typography or something and I'm just
like whoa I after-effects that never
happens yeah I've never done that so
that sounds like you'd feel good about
yourself but I don't know what that
feels like and I never will I don't have
the talent for it I have to say I also
go back and watch old vlogbrothers
videos and often think like well that
wasn't very good right of course yes
that is the thing that I'll often go
back and watch the ones I'm most proud
of and then I'll be like I used to be so
good at this but I'm not watching the
ones from like 2008 where I was like I
don't know what I'm doing why are we
still doing this there are a lot of them
that were not very good even the ones
there's a lot from any year that are not
very good like that's one of the one of
the things I really appreciate about our
our audience our community and the fact
that we've been able to have an audience
for a long time is that they're very
forgiving like you know people tend not
to walk away after one bad video which
is good because if they did everyone
would have walked away a long time ago I
don't have very many that I'm not like
that that I'm like not proud of there
are some
but there's definitely like a large body
of middle mediocre I feel like you've
made some clunkers oh yeah no I agree I
just think that the tail is like it
shrinks there at the end where there's
like there's like five videos I wish I
hadn't uploaded at all you know hmm
yeah for me that is much closer to a
hundred oh man this video of a bunch of
youtubers laughing without smiling
that's good stuff are you going through
your old wire catalog right now I might
be in Cheyenne Wyoming but at least I'm
not like googling my own name while
potting this one's really good where
Nathan Zedd took over yeah still the
best vlog brother like I would argue
like the five best log brothers are all
people up in Venice you've taken over
during paternity leave if anything maybe
we should just hand over the channel at
some point just say like well we did our
best but it turns out that like this
isn't really where our talents lie so
we're just gonna let Nathan Zed and
Sabrina Cruz take it from here like look
it's not about us
it's about a way of looking at the world
other people have that see you later I'm
gonna go hang out with my child all
right Hank we've got another question
we're just kind of we're just got a pod
we're gonna pod from now on oh god I
like hanging out with you on podcast
John and I like this part sometimes I'm
like man I wish I could do that every
single morning and then I'm like but
that's an that's five hours a week I do
not have not only that I don't think
anyone could tolerate listening to us
that much I'm sure that they're gonna be
a bunch people who are like I would
totally do it and it's like you know you
don't know what it would actually be
like you don't know that's too much it's
too much but the question the end the
answer to the question does lin-manuel
Miranda ever listen to Hamilton has to
be yes I mean he's human like the rest
of us right I mean had created Hamilton
like we would like it would be the
Infinite Jest for me I would spend the
rest of my life listening to it
as it is I'm price penned much of my
life listening to it already all right
Hank we have another question this one
comes from Tambi who writes dear John
and Hank for almost a year I've been
planning a trip to California for VidCon
for my senior trip I found out that I
had the opportunity to meet you guys on
Thursday for the meet-and-greet and I'm
going to low-key die Oh God
that's gonna be really my greatest fears
actually someone will die while meeting
me and just the stress of that obviously
I don't want to make that about me it's
gonna be a bigger deal for you Tambi and
the people who love you and I don't want
to make myself the center of that
narrative but it's hard for me not to
just because like it's you live inside
of your own body I mean I don't I find I
find these signings stressful enough
without people Loki dying okay don't
Loki die Tambe it's gonna be okay and
also now we have something to talk about
you could be like on the person who
asked that question on the pot first of
all I don't know what to have you guys
sign anything other than skin worms an
answer to that question but also ever
since I've told people I get to meet you
two they asked me if I can get something
signed for them but I know I'm only
supposed to have one thing signed and I
kind of want it to be something of mine
how do I nicely say no excitedly
conflicted Tambi mmm-hmm is there
something not nice about saying just no
yeah I feel like you just have to say no
like I I think actually you can probably
get two things signed if you're quick
about it and cool about it but yeah I
mean I think you just say like listen
I'm the one traveling to VidCon and too
bad life is full of disappointments yeah
that's the one that hey life isn't fair
no Tandy I have worked extremely hard to
try to kill the market for my signature
there are more signed copies of The
Fault in Our Stars available than there
are unsigned copies if somebody wants my
signature they could go to ebay and pay
literally two dollars for a signed copy
of The Fault no stars good call
yeah yep agree I'm really trying to
market for my signature Hank I it is it
is it is dead Johnny it is dead until
you're dead
like maybe maybe like 50 years after
you're dead there will be some kind of
weird secondary market one of the things
like I know a sort of surprising amount
about things signed by you and I do kind
of have this this brain thing that says
like someday like a signature by John
that is like has like a like a double
scribble instead of a single scribble
cuz you messed up it's gonna be like
people are gonna think that that's like
rare and pay extra for it I you know I
don't think that's true is because I
don't think that there's some like
future where my signature suddenly
becomes a big thing to have you know
right like that's the thing you are
going to become like you're not going to
become more famous after death no not
gonna be like no offense no none taken
that's no you know who's a signature I I
still have and like was such a big deal
to me when I got it was the lead singer
of the rap group onyx his name sticky
fingers he was on a plane yes once and I
got an autograph from him and I remember
thinking it was really cool and it still
is really cool to me by the way like
it's still like a valuable thing to me
but like there is no way that in fifty
or a hundred years that's going to be
like a sought-after signature and I
think I hope people who acquire
signatures really from either green
brother understand that it's you know
like we're not gonna be upset if you
part ways with that that would that
signed a book down the road or or that
signed ukelele or whatever it is like we
get it we get it it has value in that
you give it value yeah exactly this
question is not a question it comes from
Kyra John you weren't here for okay for
what this is in reference to but other
listeners probably work dear Hank and
John when I heard the question from the
anonymous home schooler who had been
poorly homeschooled I initially wondered
if maybe it had been written by me six
years ago and I had somehow not
remembered but I bet I remember that the
pod was not around six years ago I was
also very poorly homeschooled my mother
stopped attempting to teach me when I
was around 13 I also never took a real
history or science class because I was
religiously homeschooled I am now 23 and
pursuing my master's degree I want to
offer a little bit
hope to this homeschooler and to others
in similar situations I was lucky enough
to go to a community college when I was
17 and there I found many professors who
understood when I explained that I had
had a poor education and were willing to
help me learn additionally crash course
has been a great resource for me to help
fill some of the gaps there is hope we
can be taught Kyra
that's just a really nice message that I
liked and and Kyra also asked if maybe I
could be if she could be put in touch
with the anonymous home score which I
think we might try and do I also had
another update on the story of the girl
who was born on the plane John yes so we
had had it we had a long conversation
about this about like like how this
mother went into labor on the plane and
they couldn't get the plane to the
ground fast enough that the baby was
born on the plane correct it was a piper
Seneca see or something yes correct and
that it didn't make any sense because it
doesn't have a very long range like
there's you're gonna be within an hour
of your airport every time right so if
you go into labor turnaround you can't
have a baby in an hour
like it's maybe it's happened but it is
unlikely so he I was talking to a person
who was an expert in child birth she's
Midwife has been for a long time and she
she was like I was listening to the pod
and you know what happened right and I
was like no I don't know what happened
it seems very strange to me was like the
air pressure pushed the baby out and she
laughed at me and said no it was a
medical transport oh of course it was
yeah that makes sense so she's she's in
like rural Alaska or something and
they're like we need to get you on a
plane to get you to the hospital because
you're about to have this baby
you are currently in labor yeah I see
yeah it wasn't like my I was kind of
picturing that they were like you know
on their way to a vacation or something
like the just the pre baby vacation that
one takes mmm were you flying in a small
airplane in a small airplane to us you
know Lake Tahoe I don't know and that
but that makes much more sense that's
okay so now we know half the story
I would argue
we still don't know half the story and
then I guess no we actually we do know
the other half of the story because the
other half the story is that the tail
number is not necessarily associated
with the same the same had crashed okay
all right I just want to say one other
thing in response in in in response to
previous pods which is that Abby wrote
in to say Dear John and Hank I just
wanted to share that the saddest Big
Bird is in the Sesame Street movie
entitled Follow That Bird in which Big
Bird is sent to live with a family of
other birds runs away and is captured by
two guys who put him in the circus it
made me cry as a child but will always
hold a special place in my heart just
thought you guys should know childhood
and sadness Abby which I wanted to read
because I watched Follow That Bird with
Henry when he was like three or four and
Henry was like what the hell are you
doing to me and I was also like I'm
sorry I did not know what we were
getting into I thought that this is
gonna be like the other Big Bird movie
that we'd seen which was called big bird
comes home and Henry the whole time
during Big Bird comes home was like this
is horrible and I was like Henry don't
worry the movies called Big Bird comes
home he's gonna get home but then we
watching follow that bird I was like you
know what maybe this time Big Bird isn't
coming oh maybe he's gonna this is
pretty dark actually I mean Big Bird
spends a fair amount of time being sad
but I also have to say I don't want to
say this because it's gonna be hard for
me to say it without crying and I'm
gonna make other people cry okay but
saddest Big Bird is a hundred percent
big birds processional at Jim Henson's
funeral which is the thing that happened
I know emotionally wrecking true like is
brought to you by saddest big bird
the saddest big bird the saddest thing
so sad really really sad this podcast is
also brought to you by next-level
laziness next-level laziness the future
yes the future and this podcast is
additionally brought to you by infinite
water just leave your taps on and
finally this podcast is brought to you
by Hanks music hey
listen to by Hank and available at
dftba.com they were available on Spotify
I mean why would you purchase something
it's not a hundred percent available on
Spotify and you want to know why John
why cuz I'm lazy it takes it takes extra
work I'm sure it does Hank you know how
everybody always talks about like which
member of the winnie-the-pooh crew you
are like everybody's everybody's
personality is similar to one or the
other of winnie-the-pooh characters i'm
always called an Eeyore I think unfairly
for the record like I think that it's a
bit of an oversimplification to call me
sort of merely Irish and I get very
defensive about it because because I
feel like I I feel like II or gets a bad
rap in the in the Winnie the Pooh
stories like you never see the kind of
upsides of being an Eeyore of which I
would argue there are many anyway I was
just gonna say that in the world of
Sesame Street if we're gonna like give
everybody a Sesame Street character I
would say that you are very much an Elmo
thanks I'll take it you're welcome
you're welcome I'm a grover myself yeah
I think a melon Grover get it like would
bear a good team - I think that that's
good yeah yeah let's get rid of this
Winnie the Pooh stuff and just talk
about what Sesame Street character you
are that's way more interesting well I
have a really hard time figuring out
what we need the Pooh crew member I
would be like I don't I don't really
have it like maybe maybe the maybe the
owl guy because I'm pretty pretentious
and obsessed with my own intelligence
yeah I was gonna say only only owls
think that they're elves from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon Hank what is the news from
Mars this week it's bad news John it's
always bad news right does Donald Trump
not gonna not gonna get to Mars by 2024
he does say things so the bad news is
John when you shoot a cell with an alpha
particle it it has a chance of mutating
and becoming cancerous and that is the
model through which we estimated how
likely it would be for astronauts to get
cancer on their way to and while
inhabiting Mars being hit by a cosmic
rays from the Sun or cosmic rays from
the cosmos and the and the so that
that's like a sort of accepted model but
it turns out and we've known this for
some time that in fact if an alpha
particle hits one cell the chance of
cancer not just in that cell but in the
cells surrounding that cell goes up and
we have some ideas about the mechanism
of how this might be it sort of like it
creates chemicals that leave that cell
and there's a sort of a bystander cell
effect so there is a higher than one
would expect chance of getting cancer
every time you are hit by an alpha
particle or any higher energy particle
has this sort of same effect and so NASA
recently took this into account or a
study took this into account and and
said that NASA's radiation guesses are
based on an inaccurate model and they
say that if you take the more accurate
model that includes bystander cells that
might become cancerous even though they
weren't hit by a high-energy particle
that the chance of getting cancer on
your trip to Mars while you're on Mars
and your trip back doubles doubles from
if you just stayed on earth no doubles
from if you didn't if you uh-oh if you
didn't take into account yet effect yeah
doubles from our previous estimates but
it was already higher than if you just
stayed on earth oh yeah yeah and but now
it's higher than its higher it's higher
than we thought it is higher than higher
is there a sense of how high it is yes I
don't know exactly what that is though
okay in general like your chance of
death from a mission to Mars mmm-hmm
is much higher from accident than from
cancer and also the cancer will come
later
so that's something astronauts are
already risking their lives in
tremendous ways but but especially if
you consider a long-term kind of like
like program of going to Mars regularly
or people inhabiting Mars they're half
so there has to be solutions for the
cosmic-ray problem and we've got some
ideas but they are at the moment just
ideas and you'd like because there any
way we could just I I would I would
advocate for curing cancer sure that's
one just just cure every type of cancer
yep and I also am Pro that interestingly
that is not easy to do
of course yeah I know I'm aware of that
I'm aware of that issue it seems like
there's a lot of parts of going to Mars
that are hard and I for one am glad to
be right here on earth with our sweet
sweet atmosphere
speaking of Earth it is home to the
greatest third tier English soccer team
the world has ever known AFC Wimbledon
well thank the news from AFC Wimbledon
is as you know we lost our goalkeeper
James Shay he was released at the end of
the season there's a 16 year old
goalkeeper on on Wimbledon's
squad at the moment Joe burçak but he as
well looks to be moving on it looks like
he might join Crystal Palace a Premier
League side I don't think he'll be
playing for their first team to start
but very exciting for him I mean you
always want to go how many how many
sixteen year olds are there in the
Premier League or just in soccer in
general like that that seems very a lot
like it's any 16 year old who plays
soccer could be on a Premier League
youth squad but yeah it's okay he's very
he's a very promising prospect and AFC
Wimbledon have done a great job
developing goalkeepers in general also
Tom Elliot is moving on
it would appear probably to second tier
Millwall so that's great for him
unfortunately we don't get a we don't
get any kind of transfer fee for that
because he will be out of contract at
the end of the month so there's no like
financial benefit to price Wimbledon
that means that we
don't have a goalkeeper and we have one
fewer strikers which died it's not like
an ideal situation but Neil Ardley has
shown an ability to bring in great
players and I just I'm gonna we just got
to keep our fingers crossed that we've
got some people coming in who I mean are
you guys in a better financial situation
because you're in the in the better tier
or have you gotten some money for all
these players that you're sending off
yeah if if Joe burçak leaves I think
there will be a significant transfer fee
and then yeah that's part of yes the
short answer is yes and and the the club
is in a better financial position from
what I understand but it's all it's
always going to be one of this I mean
it's definitely still one of the
smallest clubs in Ligue 1 and so that
that comes with a lot of challenges but
never bet against AFC Wimbledon if I've
learned anything these last few years
it's that so hopefully hopefully it'll
all work out I'll tell you what Hank we
could get into the Premier League for a
tenth of what it would cost to get to
Mars I mean hopefully less than that
yeah actually probably probably less
than that I think that would be an
interesting proposition for NASA though
just be like listen guys this Mars stuff
it's very complicated it's it's gonna be
extremely challenging why don't you just
take 10% of your Mars budget and toss it
right into AFC Wimbledon and see if some
magic happens I mean that is a certain
kind of magic John all right I think
what did we learn today we learned that
barbecue is the great American flavor
it's true it's true we learned that John
wasn't really here most of the pond
we learned that boss baby is a really
great movie almost better than Rushmore
no I did the book book is good everybody
buy the book
[Music]
and lastly we learned that Michael
Jordan's most important work is Space
Jam of course of course it is
congratulations to Michael Jordan on his
great work on Space Jam by the way and
also to like Bob won on his great work
on boss baby which I'm sure he looks
back on his most as his most important
work as well this podcast
yep it's produced by rosianna halse
rojas and Sheridan Gibson it's edited by
Nicholas Jenkins our social media
manager is Victoria bon giorno Oh
our music is by the great gunnarolla you
take over to us on patreon at
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John or
on Twitter at Hank green or John Green
thanks to everybody for listening Hank's
thanks for potting with me and as we say
in our hometown don't forget to be
awesome
[Music]